[Musique]
si vous êtes à une saveur un des
premiers châteaux renaissance pavillon
c'est à dire un château construit sur le
principe d'une villa italienne la cour
d'honneur du château on à la cour des
écuries noble où on mettait les chevaux
du seigneur et après vous avez d'autres
cours pour le service pour les
jardiniers on a agrandi les fenêtres
mais pour le côté technique on a laissé
des croisés de pierre on appelle des
meneaux il permettait de solidifier un
petit peu toute la structure parce que
au dessus on a des fronts tant de l'uqam
qui pèse deux tonnes et demie on a des
ouvertures plus grande on a des pièces à
l'intérieur aussi beaucoup plus agréable
qui donne sur le côté sud pour avoir des
maisons à vivre agréable la vie
[Musique]
c'est des bâtisseurs un des bâtisseurs
mais avec tout leur finesse c'était eux
les maîtres sculpteurs de tous ces
fronts tant de lucarne avec des pierres
taillées très très fine
on aborde la perfection dans les visages
les doigts c'est superbe fontaine est le
cadeau des ouvriers italiens jean
lebreton et les a toujours correctement
payés en chercher le côté esthétique
agréable et fonctionnel et surtout à
bitam ce qui n'est pas tout à fait les
cada château comme chambord
c'est grandiose c'est tout ce qu'on veut
mais difficile à habiter quand même on
il n'est que quelques jours comme ça en
amenant tout son matériel c'est tout son
personnel la sotoco huile savin pouvait
être habité régulièrement c'est une
maison d'habitation à peu grande mais
voilà
[Musique]